arriving home shouldn't be hard but for
some now stuck in redless countries it's
proving worse than they could have
possibly imagined
this is what they can expect a bus to
ten days in a quarantine hotel
but that's if they can book a room there
aren't currently enough and it's left
people stranded
teresa's originally from south africa
she's been visiting her mum for what she
fears may be the final time she was
meant to return next week but she can't
get a hotel room until december the 22nd
she now faces christmas in quarantine
this turbulence of the booking and the
flight changing and then arranging
finding out where you get your pcr tests
and driving you know 10 miles to go and
book it
it takes its toll you know you force
people to do something but allow them to
do it
and the cost is crippling for families
like hannah's they must now pay
thousands of pounds not just for the
hotel but potentially to move their
flights to fit around the limited
availability it's made my mum very ill
she's extremely stressed i can't really
highlight enough not only the
incompetence of not having enough hotel
rooms for travellers coming back but the
incompetence of their booking process
it's dire it's truly dire
ten countries were added to the red list
very fast with little warning it means
quarantine capacity is less
this hotel is one of many that was being
used to quarantine red list arrivals but
isn't any more a sign perhaps just how
much smaller the operation is this time
this chain offered eight hotels last
time they now have just three made ready
by a huge team effort no mean feat says
the owner we have to get special uh
equipment in we've got to make sure
even from a room service point of view
so a lot of planning goes into it and
you know especially in the current
climate when you can't even get all your
deliveries in on time
the government says it's monitoring
things and adding to capacity but these
problems say some were predictable so i
like it when the government reacts
swiftly to a fast developing problem
what i don't like is when they don't
think around corners and they're not
prepared for the unprepared and that's
exactly what we've got here
the booking company says it's helped
thousands of travelers and recent flight
cancellations haven't helped this part
of a trip is rarely enjoyable but for
some right now it would be a relief
helen and smith sky news heathrow